I want to talk about the two main ways to
measure a network. Those are called Latency and Bandwidth.
What they mean is very different. They're often confused.
Often people say bandwidth when they mean latency, or
say latency when they mean bandwidth. They're quite different
things. So let me explain what they are. So
latency is the time that it takes for a
message to get from the source to the destination.
And that's for the start of the message. So, we can measure latency by timing
when you start sending to the time
that the receiver starts receiving. So this is
the unit of time. It will be measured in something like seconds. For a fast
network today, it's more often measured in milliseconds
and there are 1000 milliseconds in one second.
So now, you understand about latency. And when I
go back to the Greek signaling network. So, suppose now
that Zeus, who is all powerful, wanted to send a
message from Rhodes to Sparta. And he thought that the
latency of the smoke signal network as it was
currently set up was too high, that it takes too
long for the message that he sends starting from Rhodes
to reach Sparta. So the question is, how could Zeus,
and remember that in ancient Greece, Zeus was all
powerful, reduce the latency between Rhodes and Sparta. So
here are the choices. It makes the signalling nodes
further apart. So instead of going from Rhodes to
Naxos to Millios to Sparta, maybe it would have
to go one hop. There would be a new
island in the middle here, and it could go
from Rhodes to the new island and then to Sparta.
He could threaten the soldiers at all the signalling points and
scare them into working harder, so they start the fires more quickly,
when they need to send a message. He could find a way
to make it so instead of just sending one color smoke, you
could send different colors smoke. That would mean that with the same
amount of smoke, you could send more different messages. Or he could
increase the speed of light. That would mean that the the soldiers
at each signaling point would see the previous smoke signal more quickly
than they do now.